peter the topic that i wanted to pivot
to after we talked about miles garrett
and his upcoming appeal hearing earlier
is antonio brown he hasn't had any type
of a hearing yet he was interviewed last
thursday his story kind of got forgotten
in the whole colin kaepernick miles
garrett hayes of last week but but
at some point the league's got to make a
decision about antonio brown and i think
the prevailing sense is the league is
just going to kick the can all the way
to the end of the season
if however and there is some optimism
from brown's perspective that he'll be
cleared if he all of a sudden becomes
available later this season before the
post season
that becomes potentially very
interesting because
you've got some playoff teams that would
benefit from antonio brown and or would
benefit from keeping antonio brown away
from one of the other playoff teams
i think that's right mike i've thought
all along there's no way i've i've been
in sort of been in the shefter school
that says uh
you know somehow someway he's not going
to play the rest of the year i think
mike the only way that i could see a
team signing him is if the league gave
him while not a totally clean bill of
health
something more than
uh hey we're not making any decision
right now and you're as you say kicking
the can down the road mike he's got two
women who have accused him
uh basically of of uh of sexual i would
you call them crimes i guess you'd call
them crimes so i mean at this point
while with peter peter let's be clear
yeah let's be clear though there's no
criminal allegation see that's what
makes this different from other cases
there's a civil allegation and then
there's just
somebody who publicly made the complaint
it was to robert klemko then of si.com
that he did something that she didn't
like no one has ever accused him
criminally and i think that gives it a
bit of a different vibe i'm not saying
it excuses anything but we've seen the
nfl in recent years push toward finding
ways to let players get back on the
field now they may not be very happy
with antonio brown so maybe he's the
exception but but maybe maybe the path
to clearing him is easier than it would
be if there was a pending criminal
proceeding
you could very well be
very well be right mike i think the one
thing about this case that is difficult
for the nfl what happens if right now
they're in the middle of this
investigation
and they don't really know what to do
yet i mean a lot of times what the nfl
does if they're in the middle of an
investigation
or if they're looking into something
uh the player plays
and so that's right now what i think is
so difficult about this
uh from the nfl's point of view and why
you hear these optimistic things coming
out of brown's camp which i totally
understand i still think it would be
hard
for an nfl owner to stand up and say
we have a guy on our team and we're
signing a guy and we're giving him a
role on our team we have a guy who's
been accused accused
uh of something pretty serious and so
that's why i think this is going to be a
difficult thing now
mike you're an attorney or you have been
an attorney obviously so you understand
that uh more than anybody that
you're innocent until proven guilty and
all that
i just think that the smoke around this
story is going to be hard for teams to
overcome and the problem is that when
the nfl came up with the concept of the
commissioner exempt list five years ago
in the aftermath of ray rice when adrian
peterson and greg hardy were dealing
with issues that had not yet been
resolved the idea is you put the guy on
paid leave you take the heat out of the
hot kitchen from a pr perspective so you
don't have this guy on the field every
week while these allegations are being
sorted out that's all well and good it
overlooks the fact that guys want to
play football too they just don't want
to go on a paid vacation they still want
to play football but for a guy like
antonio brown who was cut by the
patriots and no one will touch him until
they know whether or not he's going to
be on the commissioner exemplist it's
created as a practical matter a nine
week unpaid suspension that antonio
brown has served while this process
unfolds so that's the problem i've had
with it and it's it's difficult to feel
all that much sympathy for antonio brown
because he's created a lot of the messes
he's endured this year but at the same
time the circumstance has conspired to
affect him in a negative way because of
the fact that no one's going to touch
him if they don't know he's going to be
on the commissioner exempt list and the
league won't say whether or not they're
going to put him on the commissioner
exempt list so he's just unpaid on a de
facto suspension and maybe maybe and
that would be the argument i'd make on
his behalf to the league look you've
already essentially suspended him nine
games without pay at what point do you
let this guy back in when there isn't a
criminal allegation when there is no
sign that there's ever going to be a
prosecution when there's one civil
lawsuit that's not going to be resolved
for multiple years most likely when do
you let this guy back in and peter you
know it's one thing to feel optimistic
it's another thing to act on it and i
think the apology that was posted
yesterday on social media by antonio
brown to the patriots and robert craft
for some of the crazy things he said
when he gets emotional when he gets
upset and he does he has no one to to
protect him from himself when he's got
his phone in his hands that that's
that's kind of going around right now
but um i digress but yeah i i feel like
he's trying to maybe lay the foundation
to get back to new england and i think
tom brady would like him to come back to
new england
i mean we'll see mike but that's my
first thought was that was my
absolutely first thought that
that antonio brown is saying to robert
kraft i mean i don't think he has to say
it very loud to to bill belichick
because i'm sure that belichick wants
him on the team
but he's saying it to robert craft right
now
hey you know mr kraft i'm i'm sorry
and so hopefully for his sake
that
uh falls on some ears that are listening
all i know is that i think there will be
quite a few people in the patriots
organization and in their fan base uh
that regardless of how much they're
struggling on offense will not want
antonio brown back on this team
yeah but i'll tell you what if he gets
thrown out into the pool of available
players and because he's a free agent he
can sign with anyone at any time if
you're the patriots and you want number
seven desperately especially if you
sense that the train is pulling into the
station for tom brady's career
and the alternative isn't okay no one
has him and we don't have him the
alternative is he joins his cousin
hollywood brown in baltimore wouldn't
that be something if the ravens grab
antonio brown for the stretch run and
the playoff run and possibly the super
bowl what if the chiefs grab antonio
brown what if any of the other teams
that the patriots may have to deal with
say we want antonio brown if the
patriots don't that raises the stakes on
the principled stand that patriots
ownership and or patriots fans may want
to
take you know i guess so mike but you
know at what cost
you know this is something that a good
portion of your fan base
i believe and and look i might be being
naive here but i think a good portion of
your fan base uh
is going to object vehemently to
uh
what would happen if some team signs
them and there's a demonstration at the
first home game that he's at
i i mean there's all these
uh intended consequences these aren't
unintended you know the these these will
happen i'd be surprised if there wasn't
some sort of organized protest if a team
signs antonio brown and it would just go
to the uh
to the uh
to the argument by a lot of people who
love the nfl
that it doesn't matter what you do off
the field the nfl can talk a good game
but it doesn't matter and i understand
he has not been convicted of anything i
get it
but
uh the the
the
the accusations are are fairly serious
and i just think that a lot of people
would protest if a team signs them
two things first first the nfl has
vetted and will be vetting and is
vetting these accusations if they
conclude ultimately that there's no
basis for punishing antonio brown that
goes a long way toward addressing the
concerns about the accusations and
secondly i remember expecting rampant
protests when mike vick came back to the
nfl remember how uninspiring those
protests were when vic who spent two
years in prison for dog fighting and
killing dogs deemed unfit to fight we'll
be back with more right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports